[Música]
Bienvenidos a esta nueva edición de
enlace andino desde Venezuela en este
programa abordaremos el tema de la
desnutrición una problemática que afecta
gravemente a niños y mujeres embarazadas
en América Latina pero que en Venezuela
se ha agudizado por la pérdida del Poder
adquisitivo y el alto costo de los
alimentos según el último reporte de la
FAO la nación caribeña encabeza la tasa
de hambre más alta de Sudamérica
22.9%, seguida de Ecuador y Bolivia
[Música]
según cifras de la fundación bengoa
cerca de 800.000 niños menores de 5 años
están en riesgo de desnutrición en
Venezuela por la inseguridad alimentaria
en las familias afectadas se prioriza
quién debe comer y quién no lo que
afecta a todo el entorno al no haber
cifras oficiales que publica el gobierno
las estadísticas que se conocen son las
difundidas por las organizaciones no
gubernamentales caritas Venezuela es
otra de las organizaciones no
gubernamentales que atiende las
poblaciones más vulnerables del país
según sus reportes la desnutrición aguda
en las zonas más pobres se estima entre
el 8 y el 10% y la desnutrición Crónica
alcanza entre el 30 y el
35%. de cada 10 niños que vienen acá
ahorita tres o cuatro ya tienen retardo
del crecimiento y llegan un momento en
el que es muy poco probable que podamos
revertir eso en un país con tantas cosas
de favor Rafael y define la situación
como crítica afirma que incluso las
personas se ven forzadas a vender sus
pertenencias o endeudarse para conseguir
unos pocos alimentos
en el año 2022 la fundación bengoa
denunció que el 20% de los embarazos en
Venezuela son de madres adolescentes que
presentan déficit nutricional al inicio
de la gestación lo cual impacta
directamente en el desarrollo del niño
aunque no hay cifras oficiales es una
realidad que a diario organizaciones
defensoras de Derechos Humanos atienden
a estas mujeres proyecto nodriza es una
de las iniciativas ciudadanas para
ayudar a madres con déficit nutricional
en uno de los barrios más emblemáticos
de la capital
Lizbeth Caraballo llegó hace tres años a
proyecto nodriza un programa de
alimentación asistencia a niños
embarazadas y madres lactantes en estado
de desnutrición y vulnerabilidad a sus
29 años su peso promedio no supera los
36 kilos porque se ha reducido la las
porciones de comida por decir la porción
que me tengo que comer yo y me la dejo
de comer para hacer a mis hijos para
Lizbeth hay días en los que este comedor
es su única fuente de alimentación
actualmente siempre cocinamos en unas
comemos una sola vez el proyecto se
sostiene gracias a donaciones y un grupo
de voluntarios que cocinan a diario para
atender en promedio a 100 personas de la
comunidad garantizándoles la proteína
diaria y batidos nutricionales
según el último informe publicado por la
Organización de las Naciones Unidas para
la agricultura y la alimentación
Venezuela tuvo un 22.9% de prevalencia
de su pavimentación la mayor en la
región esto equivale unas 6.5 millones
de personas el término supalimentada es
utilizada por la FAO para calificar a
personas en situación de hambre lo grave
Es que eso es tres veces la situación de
subalimentación de los países de América
del Sur los países de América del Sur
tienen un porcentaje de su alimentación
entre un 5 y un 8% Venezuela triplica
eso yeliani Velázquez es un ejemplo de
cómo se alimenta en promedio una familia
Venezolana en las zonas más pobres
estuvo desde el embarazo en lista de
espera de un comedor Social para
garantizarle una comida diaria a su hijo
de 4 años de edad en promedio su familia
come dos veces al día y su nevera casi
siempre luce así de vacía No siempre
compró esto Pues que es lo más lo más
barato
reconoce que en su entorno nadie está
bien alimentado y sobrevive gracias a
las verduras que encuentra en una
cascada cerca de su hogar vamos para
allá abajo para la catarata iñame como
ese no lo comemos
la inseguridad alimentaria ya no solo
problema de los sectores pobres en
Venezuela la clase media prácticamente
desaparecido en la familia promedio
comer pescado pasó a ser un lujo y poder
hacer las tres comidas diarias un reto
una de las poblaciones en riesgo son los
adultos mayores que dependen de una
pensión o de una jubilación que ronda
entre 5 y 20 dólares mensuales sus
ingresos se limitan a poder comprar unos
pocos alimentos o medicinas y sobreviven
gracias a las remesas y ayudas de
familiares según la encuesta Nacional
del observatorio de universidades en
óvubo 2022 33% de los profesores
universitarios come menos de tres veces
al día y 86% de los encuestados reduce
las porciones para rendirla en la
universidad central de Venezuela las
lavaez creó en 2021 el programa de
asistencia alimentaria directa para
ayudar con una bolsa de comida a
profesores jubilados en mayor estado de
vulnerabilidad procuramos que sea una
vez al mes eso este año insisto ha sido
muy difícil este año solo estamos
atendiendo 50 El profesor Carlos Torres
ha sido beneficiario del programa
trabaja desde hace 43 años en la escuela
de economía de la ucb sus ingresos no
superan los 6 dólares mensuales padece
insuficiencia renal y en teoría debería
cumplir una dieta estricta y comer seis
veces al día no es que no puede hacer
este la más de las tres si es que las
hago
Generalmente me las estoy saltando
porque no no tengo el tiempo o no tengo
la capacidad que existía para hacerlo el
profesor vendió su vehículo y alquiló el
puesto de estacionamiento a cambio del
pago del condominio para poder subsistir
apenas logra costear algunos alimentos
hace tiempo que nos vamos
pues no lo puedo comprar
el informe arrojó además que el 56% de
los docentes universitarios han tenido
que vender o intercambiar bienes
personales para comprar alimentos
según la última encuesta de condiciones
de vida de la Universidad Católica
Andrés Bello 8 de cada 10 venezolanos no
cuenta con los recursos suficientes para
cubrir la canasta básica que en el mes
de mayo sobrepasó los 500 dólares
mensuales para las organizaciones no
gubernamentales el primer paso para
combatir las nutriciones en Venezuela es
reconocer su existencia para el Estado
venezolano no existe una emergencia
alimentaria Pero la realidad es que en
el país se ha normalizado ver a las
personas buscar comida en la basura o
asistir a comedores sociales para paliar
el hambre hasta aquí esta misión de
enlace andino desde Venezuela Recuerden
que pueden sintonizarnos a través de
triple W punto com